hmm reminder to raise your hand and we
will pass a microphone your way also
please state your name and affiliation
before asking your question Nick left
side front with Doug thank you Doug
Smith for the Toronto Star I guess you
really didn't have to worry about how
your young guys Pascal and Freddie would
handle the enormity of the moment
they're both how do you think they
played there they were both really good
you know especially obviously Pascal had
a big offensive night I thought he he
played with really good composure right
he got to the his spots and and got on
balance and was patient and and when he
needed to go quick and get around I mean
he did as well and he a couple couple of
real tough ones go in for him as well
but Freddie did a good job Freddie
worked hard defensively played a lot of
minutes on curry and I know I know curry
had 34 but Freddie Freddie made him work
for him Dan like you at the Los Angeles
Times senators like Marcus all don't
always aren't always able to stay on the
court I guess a team like the Warriors
how was he able to be so effective
tonight well he's a really good defender
right and a lot of that comes from I
always say it a lot of it comes from
desire to be a good defender and the
want to stay on the court right but I
think his his IQ is really high he knows
he knows how to get out there and he's
shown over the last few games or maybe
more than that but he's he's pretty good
when he gets a mismatch on it on a
shooter he'll he went up in the last
series and guarded Middleton really well
on we know when there'd be a breakdown
and he'd end up way out on the floor on
those guys and I thought he he did a
decent job on some of those guys tonight
just just really good reactions left
side v Raonic Arash no Danny with
Sportsnet coach over here Golden State
down 17 down 18 to Portland the Western
Conference final they're able to come
back and win they never really got
ignited tonight how were you able to
make sure they didn't go on their
trademark runs well I think you know the
big thing is you got a you got to
continue to play defense
all throughout the game even even though
you're you know you're trying really
hard sometimes and they'll come down and
they'll they'll make you look silly
sometimes they'll hit the boom layup and
you're just like man what happened how
did that happened fast and you know I we
just said that some of those breakdowns
will happen you know or we need our weak
side to be good we were close a few on
and just didn't rotate on a few of those
but you take it out and you go back down
and you try to answer you know without
you get a shot and you try to answer and
you try not to have any droughts on
offense because I mean you know their
ability to score quick I think again as
I kept saying in the Milwaukee series
offense is really important for us here
taking care of the ball and getting
shots and getting some to go through the
net because if they take it from me
they're down the floor in a hurry
probably spraying for a three and if
they're playing off the rim all the time
they're coming downhill fast at you and
either at the rim or spraying right side
in the back Tim Nick Tim Reynolds with
the AP we've been talking all postseason
about you know Kyle gets criticized for
not scoring which is you know sort of
silly by now but he just finds ways and
tonight it was you know the lead leading
the past is taking charges against
boogie things of that nature can you put
into words how much his willing to
sacrifice on literally any play at any
time means in games like these well I
think that um the you know one of the
best things about this team is that you
don't have to put a burden of 20 to 25
points on him you know the the because
he's gonna defend he's gonna lead the
team he's gonna plate make those tough
plays he just instinctually does that
game after game after game and the
scoring it's great it's it's I'm not
gonna say it's like icing on the cake we
need a scoring and we certainly need
spacing and and some of his head down
drives or he makes contact and gets to
the line you know those are really
important but but again I think the this
team can a lot of times absorb some
nights where he just plays really well
and doesn't score I mean he plays really
well and doesn't score much that's
nothing wrong with that right side
second row fill
hey Nick Phil barber Santa Rosa Press
Democrat I know that a building can't
win a basketball game but what did you
feel in the arena tonight and what do
you think it did for your team well it
gave us a couple nice bounces I think we
had a couple a couple of shots go in
that that were kind of eyeopener's let's
say but that you know the fans obviously
we're great they were loud they were
exciting I think they were into it and
that's the way it should be man that's
that's what home court is and our fans
deserve a bunch of credit for for being
a big part of that
left-side sector Roda mark Nick mark
Schwartz ESPN knowing Pascal see
Ockham's story and how he was discovered
in camera room but not really known to
be a basketball prospect even when
maasai saw him seven years ago he didn't
look like an NBA player how is it
possible for a kid with so little
background to come up in this situation
and do what he did tonight in this stage
yeah it's it's it's pretty incredible
right for it first of all but I think it
was two years ago mark when when we we
got bounced out of the playoffs we
literally went in the gym the next day
and he was he was kind of like listen I
need to learn how to shoot I see that in
playoff basketball you better be able to
shoot to be on the floor so went to work
thatin that day on his shooting and I
think we changed some mechanics but
that's a very small thing he took it and
just absolutely ran with it you know two
three times a day every day just just
trying to get that part of his game
better right and and that just shows
again he was he was extremely
hard-working like beyond I mean just
just super super committed to to find in
a place in this league and improving his
game but but I you know I've heard you
know a lot of people or him say some
things this year and they keep saying
are you surprised
and he keeps saying no this is what I've
always envisioned for myself so I think
that's a powerful statement he makes as
well he he believes in himself and he
went to work at it
two more questions in the middle for
throw Kayla coach Kayla great TSN you
guys took quite a few threes at the
beginning of the game was that just
taking what the defense was giving you
or were you trying to really establish
you guys in your presence outside yeah I
mean we're always gonna take try to take
what's there and I agree with you I said
a couple times early in the game I said
if we shot a two yet you know we have we
shot I kept asking I have in Pascal a
shot one but I think we've taken eight
of our first nine shots or threes but
they were you know they were open and
and I and I love it because you know the
one thing that that we must do in this
series so that we need to do is go for
it and that just showed our no hesitancy
confidence and willing to just kind of
go for it find a question left side in
the back Stephen Stephen long Sports Net
hi Stephen Danny Green like really
struggled in Milwaukee serious like with
with his three-point shooting but it
seems tonight he he seemed to kind of
get that monkey off his back Oh what did
you see from from him yeah I mean I
think I think one thing that's been
interesting is as the series change and
a new team comes in and and all those
things that certain guys it fits and
certain guys it doesn't in in the
rotation or even in the starting lineup
and and it just you know Milwaukee just
wasn't his series and it was it was
probably good to get that one over with
in his view and kind of get a clean
slate and that's you know that's what we
said it's a new series new team forget
about what's what's happening and you
got to do that game to game now too
right you you you got to understand that
some guys aren't gonna shoot as well
every night or or is worse every night
so each night we try to find who's who's
going and who's got a chance and try to
keep those guys out there rolling Thank
You Nick all right thank you